Donald Trump was campaigning in Iowa
last night and he responded to what
happened in Colorado it's no wonder
crooked Joe Biden and the far-left
lunatics are desperate to stop us by any
means necessary they willing to violate
the US constitutions at levels never
seen before in order to win this
election Joe Biden is a threat to
democracy it's a threat they're
weaponizing law enforcement for
highlevel election interference because
we're beating them so badly if we're to
believe the polls what Trump is saying
right there is true I mean virtually
every poll right now when they show you
the head-to-head Trump and Biden Trump
is now winning now I want to show you
some of the reaction from across the
political spectrum and most of it
actually was pretty good but here's
rfk's response every American should be
troubled by the Colorado Supreme Court's
decision to remove president Trump from
the ballot he continued with about an
eight tweet thread but that gets to the
heart of